benvenuti a nuovo esperimento
incredibile oggi faremo purissima costa
abbiamo tutti gli ingredienti parti
spagna tutta creme e poi abbiamo
ingrediente principale il dottor un
tasto dottore oggi toccato punto più
basso di facebook
[Musica]
apri pure la cloche che senso quindi
mettere la testa io so mettere la mia
testa si scemo io no nel senso che lei
deve fare una cosa con la mia testa tu
di legge una torta
di cucina viene sì in forno o capitolo
nicola robben faccia una buona
no per ogni romanzo e io vi ammazzo
cifre oggi 9 avere conduttrice di pe
coop italia come ospiti conduttrice
essere benedetta parodi conduttrice come
zinco rame e altri metalli che voi
conoscete bene oggi farà esperimento
molto particolare a chiamarsi porta di
totò
[Musica]
cominciamo col pan di spagna
allora attenzione perché io devo mentre
tocca ad amarsi come già fatto che non
poter neanche passeggino sperare non
scaduto almeno quello
i capelli non andate tanto bene e
benefici per staglianò fa credito cove
essere passion adesso decorare primo
anello di pan di spagna con crema al
cioccolato alle piazze dottore piacere
ma non speculare sul naso essere buona
molto simile da molto pulita questa
torta perché avere stati dentro qualcuno
vede questa pasta tutto torre sentire
anche in mutande in questo momento
nessuno dottoressa benedetta smettiamola
con queste cose per cortesia notoria
sentire tutto nella camicia o del viver
avere otto chili dentro la camicia
sensazione di nutella in camicia e sarà
inspiegabilmente piacevole cazzo a parte
su in giro
adesso deve problema perché dovrebbe
mettere al posto noi fotowatio ci metta
le coste siano che facciano respirare
niente per favore e conobbe i figli e
gli ambienti licenziati dopo questo
video negozi è seduto dove soffocare
sito torni a soffocarne contesto e
budget per questo video tizia dottore di
non mangiare dottore voleva solo morino
e benedetta non si preoccupi quelli
lasciati cazzi e tanto a serre arrivati
a un graffio al volto per cortesia deve
far domanda
lei essere esperta di cucina quando più
o meno mancare infine percentuale più o
meno di completa mare di roma come mi
posso pulire
gasport mai provate invece a porta
volevo in una mano per giudicare
[Musica]
[Applauso]
io metterei un po fiorellini come
chiamarti che al momento del terrore ma
lasciate poi facciamo vittoria sentito
in guerra questo nome tante volte
zuccarini signora visse questo video non
arrivare a un milione di mi piace totò
che venire a casa di ognuno di voi per
avere anche un pò negli occhi io mai più
stato rifatto una cosa decina neanche io
farò ma andare bene tanto script di
video paris ambienti quindi esperimento
riuscito portati totore bellissimo
esperimento fuoco il sito benedetta però
grazie voler ricordare a tutti i fan che
benedetta essere tutti i venerdì su
canale 31 real time con petroff italia
si vedeva 21 10 tutti viene fib corso
che il conduttore carissimo e il dottore
essere non brava fare totti ma lei sì
quindi guardare comunque assistente sa
che è stata molto brava quindi
promuovere addotto ressa avevo si è
fantastico dove essere anche mago visto
benedetta comunque totale ha ritrovato
tutti quanti che esperimenti canile
stare per tornare sul canale quindi
rimanere sintonizzati stagione due in
arrivo ci sapremo ci saremo e adesso chi
sapeva di poter mangiare tutto io
tagliando il dottore no tagliate
sbagliamo
[Musica]